oh it got to your it gets it in it gets
in your nose really quickly back later
holy [ __ ]
lay back are you okay you see on any
better
yeah I'm really nervous
I haven't eaten anything I really like
spicy food and I'm Nigerian so I feel
like a lot of my meals are spicy I to me
this I'm a little hungover right now and
I'm really not feeling this and I've
like had like phantom diarrhea pains
thinking about this all day
[ __ ] yeah that is it's actually being
nicely um roasted of sun-dried I mean
it's it's yeah [ __ ] absolutely right
it's not white hmm there is no delay an
app which makes you think that I got
some seeds it does taste good it does
taste good and it real and I think I'm
gonna cry it's good okay I would I would
put this on pizza um
I thought I can beat it like so you were
some Scottish yeah um I'm nitrile a bit
more
not anymore of it yet because the others
did that and that was the major problem
that they have and done I don't know if
Jen deal with my body yeah I'm starting
a little bit this week it's not the
worst thing that's ever happened
well that's gone in my mouth but I'm
really glad you didn't pull out coke
cooler because that would like be the
worst thing in the world some people
really stupidly do by Indian restaurants
I don't know it I want it done it was
like a really weird mix of like
delicious and horrible [ __ ] I think I'm
gonna throw up you guys okay it's let us
not like as hot as I was expecting and
kind of proves my theory that the
basically those scale ranking legal
[ __ ]
[Music]
it's good because there's
air-conditioner